[Music]
good morning and thanks for being with
us tensions over taiwan have escalated
overnight china has launched military
drills which taiwan says are an invasion
of its territory and that live fire
exercises in the sea and airspace around
the island are breaking united nations
rules it's seen as a direct response to
a visit by to the island by a senior u.s
politician nancy pelosi a provocation
that's led to china which considers
taiwan to be part of its territory to
warn that those playing with fire will
get burned joe pike reports
in china there may have been anger
we come in friendship
to taiwan
we come in peace
for the region
nancy pelosi spoke of peace but she
knows this visit is provocative
today the world faces a choice between
democracy
and autocracy
america's determination to preserve
democracy here in taiwan and around the
world
remains ironclad
in response china has launched targeted
military action including firing
long-range ammunition and testing guided
weapons
it is a display of military might as
well as one of anger aimed at the us
raise the tensions in the taiwan strait
and embolden the arrogance
of the taiwan independence forces
this is a highly dangerous trick
such as playing with fire
and those
playing with fire will get pumped
the self-governing island is surrounded
by south korea and japan to the north
and the philippines to the south but
china is its closest neighbor just 112
miles away and beijing sees it as a
breakaway province
later this week in six areas surrounding
taiwan the chinese military is expected
to carry out further exercises including
live fire drills
by the time this became a topic as to
whether she should go or not it was
already too late knowing the speaker
to persuade her otherwise and it
probably wasn't in our interest at that
point to let china talk us out of it
even if maybe it would have been better
that she not go at all in the first
place
this trip is largely popular with
members of congress but in the 3d chess
of international diplomacy the privately
voiced reticence in the white house and
pentagon may be linked to concerns about
a different part of the world ukraine so
far the chinese have not provided any
significant military support to vladimir
putin such as their world-class drones
but some here worry this visit may mean
that could change
the taiwanese government will be
delighted these pictures are being
beamed around the world even with the
greater risk of escalation and
confrontation
joe pike sky news washington
well our security and defense editor
deborah haynes is with us here now
good morning to you so as joe was saying
there is a threat of escalation it just
how likely is that that china the
rhetoric has been really strong
china is clearly furious at this visit
the fact that you had the chinese
ambassador to the uk yesterday convening
this press conference it's very rare
that that he does that unlike his
predecessor and the language that he
used was of outrage warning about that
threat of if you he called the uk he
said that the us was playing a highly
dangerous trick and then if you play
with fire you'll get burnt but clearly
neither side is going to want this to
escalate into a full-on confrontation
confrontation between the u.s and china
both nuclear powers could lead to a new
world war let's face it
however the risk right now given china's
angry response to this visit with these
very large-scale live-firing drills from
the air and from the sea is that there
is a mistake an accident and there is an
accidental escalation into direct
confrontation between china and
taiwanese forces and then the question
is how does the u.s respond clearly
we're not in that space at the moment
but it's a very dangerous time and the
tripwire is there for further
confrontation certainly okay deborah for
now thank you so much thanks for coming
in all right well joining us now from
taipei is a journalist at taiwan plus
james chater james good to have you with
us today thanks for being with us so
look what's the reaction been so far on
the island and in taipei to place's
visit and what do we expect her to be
doing today
well pelosi earlier on today hers has
met with taiwanese legislators in in
taiwan's parliament she then met with
taiwan's president um and then is
expected to to do some more meetings
later on this afternoon before flying
off um at 5pm you know the the reception
has largely been warm um i think the the
level of nervousness has definitely
tipped up um in the earlier hours of
today as we've started to learn more
about these live fire drills which are
taking place around the whole of the
main taiwanese mainland
we've seen in there some of the reports
coming out now that these live fire
drills are taking taking place as close
as 12 nautical miles to the taiwanese
mainland and it's important to point out
because you know the chinese military
does do does engage with these sorts of
um intimidatory uh tactics usually you
know it's a regular occurrence for for
the chinese um air force to send
aircraft into taiwan's air defense
identification zone but to see live fire
drills taking place around the entirety
of the taiwanese mainland really is um
you know a marx kind of escalation in
terms of what we've seen previous
okay james chater there in taipei for us
thank you so much for that
of course more on that story throughout
the morning here on sky news now the
life support of 12 year old archie
battersby is due to be withdrawn this
morning at 11am after his family lost a
supreme court bid to keep it going
however his parents say they'll be
asking the european court of human
rights to intervene in the last ditch to
delay turning off their son's life
support sergio choudhury reports
archie battersby's heart is still
beating
but that could all change in the next
few hours
basically
i've gone into the other room because
i've i've blown my top a bit
and gone to see archie
and while i'm
stroking archie's head i get an email
from our legal team
saying that the hospital the trust of
uh very brutal i've been
very brutal and
are refusing
to let archie go to a hospice
it's a decision that came after months
of legal proceedings at both the high
court and the court of appeal before the
family ultimately took their case to the
united nations under its convention on
the rights of persons with disabilities
i did stay i would fight for the bitter
end with archie and as his mum that's
exactly what i've done and i hope i've
passed away for any other parents that
when i go up against
a trust
in this country and the justice system
it needs reforming dramatically needs
performing it's it's not right it's not
fair it's not right
the un response was swift an injunction
on britain to continue archie's
treatment but the british government
wasn't going to listen
in a most unusual step the health
secretary intervened to tell judges here
at the country's highest appeals court
that the u.n convention isn't binding
because it hasn't been incorporated into
uk law
the supreme court which had been asked
by the family to give archie more time
refused the appeal leaving some human
rights lawyers puzzled
on the face of it
the uk government could say well
if you're not going to go out to stay
for the u.n committee on the rights of
disabled why should you grant a stay on
the basis of a treaty that's also not
incorporated in the uk law therefore
we're going to start sending people off
to rwanda
the trust treating archie says it will
move ahead with the court-ordered
withdrawal of treatment
but for his mother holly dance the fight
continues she says she'll take the case
to the european court of human rights
with just hours to go before her child's
life support is removed sadia chowdhury
sky news in london
well our reporter matthew thompson is
covering this for us this morning and
joins us now live from the royal london
hospital matthew good morning to you so
just a heartbreaking story
where did this go from here what can the
family expect to happen in the next few
hours do we think
well we really are entering the final
stages of this long legal fight
for archie's family
at 11 o'clock today his life support is
due to be switched off but that's
pending this application to the european
court of human rights the family have
until nine o'clock
this morning to make that application
and they have indicated that they're
going to do so his family would like him
to die what they've been calling a
natural death they'd like to move him to
a hospice to receive care
in his final days and this is really as
i say the final legal hurdle that they
can
attempt to
jump over if you like the echr really is
after you've just been hearing a
succession of uh challenges in the high
court here in the in the supreme court
in the court of appeal but i'm afraid
legal experts believe that it has slim
chances of success you might remember in
the similarly tragic circumstances in
2017 the case of charlie gard the east
hr simply refused to intervene so whilst
we shouldn't prejudge this case i'm
afraid the weight of legal precedent
isn't an archie's family's favor okay
matthew for now appreciate it i will
speak to you again later thank you
now let's take a look at the morning's
newspapers and we'll start off with the
front page of the metro which picks up
on that story about archie heartbreak
for archie's family is how the metro put
it they say the judge has decided that
the 12 year old's life support can be
switched off
the times leads with a poll showing
two-thirds of tory party members prefer
liz truss as the next prime minister and
next lead with the party of course
the telegraph reports that voting has
been delayed because of a
cyber threat to the election process on
the dead express has an interview with
liz truss and says that she's the only
candidate who can deliver the growth
that britain needs
well let's get more now on how it's
looking in the race to replace boris
johnson our uh politics correspondent
amanda akas is with us now amanda good
morning morning let's pick up on what we
saw there on the front page of the
newspaper first of all on that security
fear about these ballots being sent out
they were meant to go out beginning of
the week but they have been delayed
yes as if the conservative party
leadership race hadn't been dramatic
enough now we're told that threats from
cyber hackers mean the start of the
voting has been delayed and there's also
been a change to the way it's being run
as well so plans for members to be able
to change their votes online something
the rasheed sunex team had been hoping
would give him a bit of a chance to make
up some of that ground he's lost to liz
trust potentially have been dropped the
parties say they've been speaking to the
national cyber security center that's
part of gchq about this and have
therefore decided to beef up security
and they've written to members to
explain all of this saying they will get
their ballots sent out uh this week
now we don't know about any specific
threats but of course we know that china
russia iran have all been accused of
interfering in overseas elections
recently as for the candidates well
they're due in cardiff later on today
for another hustings events with tory
party members it's been a bruising 24
hours or so for liz trusts after her
u-turn over that flagship part of her
warren whitehall waste policy we were
talking about yesterday forced to drop
her plans for regional job boards which
he said would save 8.8 billion pounds by
um meaning lower pay for public sector
workers in future outside london and the
south east there was a huge backlash
against that yesterday morning from tory
mps concerned about the impact on their
leveling up agenda over this and so
she's had to back down on that but good
news for her from the polls um showing
that sixty percent of members now saying
they're going to vote for her compared
to 26 percent rishi sunak so really
widening the gap there and worse for him
nine in ten party members say they've
already made up their minds we'll have
more on the polling in about 10 minutes
with our pollen pitch certainly will you
took the worst right out of them thank
you so much for that and a reminder if
you needed it that tomorrow rishi sunak
and liz trust will both take part in a
live special program it's called the
battle for number 10 it will be here on
sky news and it will be hosted by k
burley it starts at 8.
now the united states has warned its
citizens that there may be revenge
attacks targeting them following the
drone strike that killed al-qaeda's
leader aiman al zawahiri over the
weekend our u.s correspondent mark stone
has been speaking to the fire chief
joseph pfeiffer who lost a brother in
the 911 attacks and was close to the
north tower of the world trade center
when the first plane hit
it was a beautiful
summer day like like today bright
sunshine
and i was standing in the street
and i saw
the first plane
aim and crash into the world trade
center
on september the 11th 2001 joseph
pfeiffer was the first new york fire
chief to reach the twin towers
within a 102 minutes
both world trade center towers collapsed
to the ground
went completely dark
that we couldn't see the hand in front
of our face
and we wondered if we were still alive
343 of his men died in the towers that
day
his brother kevin among them
the zawahiri's death now
make a difference for you all these
years on
hearing the
the news
that
one of the masterminds of 9 11
was taken out
allowed me a sense of closure
it allowed
us victims of terrorism
to have a voice
that were heard
that their terrorists
won't be tolerated
and that their acts
are
our acts against humanity
ayman al-zawahiri was quite literally
osama bin laden's right-hand man the
brains of al-qaeda behind the face we
all know
more than anywhere else this is the
place which bears the scars of his work
new york manhattan ground zero a calm
now in the heart of a city ripped apart
zawahiri's protection by the taliban his
presence in kabul all that fundamentally
undermines the taliban claim that it is
a reformed organization where he was
protected more will be too afghanistan
is an enduring challenge but for the
victims
21 years of pain has eased just a little
mark stone sky news in new york
okay let's take a look now at some of
today's other news headlines and a 20
year old man has been charged under the
treason act after an incident in the
grounds of windsor castle last christmas
the crown prosecution service said that
jason singh a child who's from
southampton had been charged with being
near to the person of the queen
willfully producing a loaded crossbow
with intent to use to
injure the person of her majesty
a new report from the rac says that
major retailers are failing to reduce
petrol prices in line with falling
wholesale costs
the automotive services company says
that the wholesale cost of unleaded is
now back to early may prices but drivers
are paying more than 50 pence extra per
liter
and voters in kansas in the us have
turned out in record numbers to reject
efforts to tighten the state's abortion
laws it comes after the u.s justice
department filed a lawsuit that
challenges restrictive abortion
legislation in idaho it's the first
major action by the justice department
challenging a state since the supreme
court overturned roe versus wade in june
now a snorkeler has suffered a suspected
shark attack off the coast of cornwall
yes the swimmer was reportedly bitten on
the leg by one of those things that's a
blue shark this happened near penzance
on thursday now they were on a
snorkeling tour the company behind it
says that the instant is extremely rare
and they're talking to sharp experts
about what happened the coast guard has
said the snorkeller was put in the care
of the ambulance service to treat the
leg injury the swimmer was able to walk
away afterwards despite suffering that
injury and confirmed that the beaches
have not been closed
now labour has criticized liz trust
after her campaign argued it could save
billions if it paid public sector
workers in cheaper regions of the
country less than their counterparts in
the capital and the south of england the
tory leadership front-runner has now
abandoned the policy insisting it had
been misrepresented
well let's bring in shimano mahmoud
she's the labour mp for lady wood in
birmingham and is the party's national
campaign coordinator shimano mahmoud
thank you so much for being with us and
good morning
to you um i wonder if we can just pick
up if we makes i think i know what
you're going to say about that liz trust
policy and which she's rode back on but
i wonder if we can pick up on how well
the labour party doing right now against
the conservative parties there is a lead
in the polls the latest polls that have
come in but only a one percent lead why
is it still so tight
oh well look i mean uh the polls of the
last few months have been showing uh the
labor party uh in the lead uh by
differing and varying amounts but as a
labour party's national campaign
coordinator i'm not uh following uh the
movements of individual polls here and
there that the main thing that matters
is that we are um that we are uh taking
our case to the country that kierstarma
has you know achieved in two years what
um neil kinnick for example took about
eight years to to achieve in terms of
turning the party around making us
electorally competitive again once when
we went down to that defeat in 2019 our
worst uh for nearly a century um you
know people were writing us off for a
decade or more not only has uh kia under
his leadership brought us back into
contention got us back on the pitch but
we are out there we are making progress
as we did in the local elections which
took place all over the uk just in may
this year we're winning key uh
by-elections as well so we are making
very solid progress under kiers
leadership working from that very low
point of our 2019 general election uh
defeat so that that those are the real
indicators for the progress that the
labour party is making you'll forgive me
if i'm not going to uh you know comment
on every single poll there's many polls
they have different methodologies
they're showing slightly different
things mostly they're showing that the
labour party is in the lead ahead of the
conservative party but for me what
matters is are we making progress in all
of the areas that we need to be winning
in if we are going to win and get a
majority labor government at the next
general election and the answer based on
the local election results and the
by-election results that we've been
getting is yes yeah and shabbat i
wouldn't expect you to comment on all
the polls but i would expect you to have
a thought about why it is seemingly so
tight still considering the disarray
that the conservative party have been i
mean they just
ejected the prime minister and now
they're battling it out to replace him
and the labour party is only a smidgen
ahead
well no well partly what you're going to
see reflected in some of the some some
of the polls that are taking place at
the moment is a is is a recalibration in
the sort of post boris johnson uh era
for the conservative party but as i said
you know for for me as i plan ahead to
the next general election for the labour
party uh with a you know with a clear
strategy to get to a majority labour
government at that next general election
which will be a stunning achievement
based on our 2019 general election
result what i'm focusing on is not
individual polls uh which will fluctuate
and the polls have been extremely
volatile for some time now uh there are
a lot of voters out there who are up for
grabs as it were who haven't made up
their mind and who are willing to change
their mind and it's our job to take the
case to them for the labour party and
persuade them to trust us with their
vote at the next general election
whenever it comes and as i say we have
made progress
uh if you look at our results in the
local elections where we won in the
popular vote across uh the seats that we
would need to win in order to form a
majority labor government we were
winning the popular vote uh in many of
those seats which means that we will be
winning them at a general election uh if
that was taking place now and we made
progress uh in the wakefield by election
a seat that we took off the tories only
a few weeks ago which had added as it
were to boris johnson's uh woes and was
was a key driver in removing the prime
minister from his position so the labour
party is making electoral progress in
the ways that it matters which is actual
results that are being delivered on the
ground
i appreciate that shimano no one's
disputing the progress that's been made
it was a really low ebb when the party
was led by jeremy corbyn so to move on
from that is uh something that
definitely should have happened but i
wonder if this is a an issue of
leadership at the moment there is still
a problem isn't there with whether
labour party members people in the
shadow cabinet can go on to pick it
lines can you just clear up what the
decision has been made by zakir starm as
to whether people should be on the
picket lines because we saw lisa and
andy there a couple of days ago she was
recommended but not sacked sam terry was
set to a few days hence before for being
on a picket line
well look there's a there's a clear
difference between both of those uh
instances and so
let me just explain you know because
care has made very clear that we are a
government in waiting we want the the
people of our country to put us into
government at that next election and we
want that election as soon as possible
and think it should happen as soon as
the new tourney prime minister is
elected a government in waiting has to
behave seriously like a government and
and be the you know model the behavior
that we would have in government if
you're a government minister you need to
be able to get around a negotiating
table with public sector unions pay
officials worker bodies representatives
and get to fair negotiations and act in
good faith you can't do that if you walk
off you know if you get to that
negotiating table by picking from
picketing at a picket line so it's been
very clear that you know labour front
venture should not be picketing at a
picket line but there is a world of
difference between that and uh you know
members of parliament meeting workers in
their constituency talking to them about
the issues that are affecting them their
pay their conditions how they're
struggling with a cost of living uh
crisis that is behavior you'd expect not
just from labour mps by the way but
you'd expect it from all members of
parliament to engage with their
constituents and talk to them about the
issues that are affecting them that's
what lisa was doing the reason that um
sam terry was uh was uh removed from his
post was because he broke collective
responsibility when it came to doing a
media round from a picket line and
making up a labour party policy on the
hoof that is not acceptable for labor
front ventures you would expect us all
to maintain discipline and collective
responsibility when that is broken there
will be consequences but there is a
world of difference between that case
and all members of parliament wanting to
engage with their constituents as is
completely right and proper i would
expect tory mps to be engaging uh with
workers in their constituency if they
profess to care about how the cost of
living crisis is affecting everybody
they should be talking to workers as
well
siobhan and you've made your point very
forcefully thank you very much you might
have removed national campaign
coordinator for the labour party thank
you time
all right let's dig into some of the
polling we'll not talk about labour just
yet we'll talk about the stories we're
joined by uh the research director from
uk patrick english to dig into some of
the latest polling you've done patrick
good morning to you thanks for being
with us now the first poll here is going
to make delightful reading for the trust
camp i think we can bring it up huge
lead has been drawn out by liz trust yes
that's right so what we found in our
latest polling with concerted party
members is that rishi sunak has made no
progress climbing the mountain that we
found him at the bottom of at the start
of this campaign in fact rgb has fallen
back a bit further into the valley list
trust has extended her lead over rishi
sunaki knows head to head so that's
among people of conservative party
members who gave us an intention who
said that they wish had an idea about
who they were vote for and that's 69 for
trust and 31 for sunak an interesting
thing that we've noticed and continually
noticed throughout this campaign is that
though this trust is winning against
younger voters older voters those who
voted leave rishi sunak is ahead among
conservative party members who voted to
remain so that's kind of the one area
where he is which is strange isn't it
absolutely since liz trust was quite a
prominent remain campaigner in the 2016
referendum racism of course backed
brexit and has been quite vocal about
how he backed brexit in 2016. see him
ahead with remainers and trust ahead
with levers it's quite interesting what
does that tell us about sort of the
sentiments of those voters does it say
that the centuries part of the party is
more backing of which you see that do we
think
probably that's the case yes i think as
well for liz trios has been the caller
the born again brexiteer element is very
strong liz trust became the face
arguably that's kind of post-brexit
global britain when she was in the paper
she was on the news signing trade deals
and she had quite a big sort of social
media campaign around that so i think
that's reflected in the results we're
seeing now absolutely okay let's talk to
us about some of the polling around
whether it's right for boris johnson to
resign this is quite interesting as well
it tells you a little bit about the
thinking that's going on in some
conservative party members heads let's
bring that up if we can
this is the question was put was it
right for mps to oust the pm you can see
the numbers there 53 say was the wrong
decision yes exactly so a majority just
about just about over a majority of
conservative members think that it was
the wrong decision for mps to
effectively remove boris johnson however
41 say it was right so i think we can
characterize the party is very much
split on this issue and i think probably
what this does is it plays a little bit
into things we see before liz trust of
course did not resign versus hunak did
and was sort of seen as a catalyst of
the eventual resignation of boris
johnson so perhaps this hurt is playing
a little bit into the voting tension as
well and following on from that you've
also had some ask the question who they
prefer as pm and if all three of them
are up trust sunac and johnson we can
see that they would still prefer boris
johnson to be the prime minister
absolutely and this highlights uh
the whole i think the conservative party
is in right now and the frustration
perhaps one of the conservative party
members when we were polling at the
beginning of this race very few of them
were saying that they'd like lose trust
or richard sunak to be in that final two
it was all about ben wallace it was all
about penny morton kemi baden knock was
polling very very well so i think
perhaps that's what we're seeing here is
that the conservative party membership
aren't that enamored with the choice in
front of them and probably rather boris
johnson stay within those two but of
course that's not the choice in front of
them no it's certainly not at this point
and i said we'd come to it let's look at
the national voting intention now and as
you can see i said to shabana mahmoud
that labour party were only just ahead
and you can see it's just one percentage
point there i mean how do you guys view
this polling right now should labour be
doing way better considering what's been
happening with the conservative party
yes i think probably first off it's
important to know that this is of course
just one poll and we're kind of we want
to see a couple of further polls from us
that have a narrowing lead to be sure
that there has been some movement in
that direction but i think there are two
reasons to expect perhaps that the gap
would narrow the first is of course the
conservatives have got rid of a deeply
unpopular prime minister prime minister
the public didn't think should be in the
job who they didn't trust and now with
him gone perhaps the fault of seeing a
bit of a concerned party rebound
secondly of course the news cycle has
been consistently about the conservative
party now for the best part of a month
so with them considering all the time
sort of in the polls and conservative
party policy being discussed over and
over i think perhaps that's playing into
it a little bit as well so of course
it's one poll we're going to have to
wait to see but there's a reason to
suspect that the gap should narrow
certainly should and how many people
have been asked this question patrick
what's the just over 1500 okay pretty
good hold on yeah that's pretty good
all right patrick english from youtube
really appreciate your time
thank you all right
now let me just remind you again that
tomorrow wish you soon like and this
trust are going to both take part in a
live special program here on sky news
it's called the battle for number 10.
it's going to be hosted by k burley and
it will begin
at 8 00 pm do not miss it
all right let's take a look at what the
weather has in store for the next couple
of days
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the weather will settle down towards
the weekend as high pressure builds but
it will be wet at times today for some
thicker cloud patchy rain and hill fog
will affect southern parts of england
this morning meanwhile a band of showery
rain will push southwards across
scotland northern ireland and the
republic blustery showers will continue
in the north and the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and we're parts of the world's
experiencing extreme weather conditions
remember what it was like here a couple
of weeks ago let's take a look at the
impact that climate change is having on
the planet right now this is our climate
change dashboard revealing exactly how
the world has changed global warming
since 1880 you can see there the real
time power mix using a lot of gas no
coal 45 renewables on the top left we
show you how much warmer the earth is
now from 1880 and that's when modern
record keeping began and finally bottom
left the total amount of co2 emissions
in millions of tons but that figure
there 45 renewables is good considering
the situation the planet finds itself in
now
princess charlotte's joined the duke and
duchess of cambridge your mum and dad to
her at the commonwealth games yesterday
and here are some pictures of her
lovely stuff the seven-year-old was at
the games and the papers have picked out
a bunch of pictures of her pulling funny
faces there are some nice pictures of
her just looking completely normal like
a seven-year-old but she seems to be
having a lovely time there giving dad a
thumbs up i wonder if it was because he
said she could have chips for lunch now
does it remind you of anyone else of
course it does earlier this summer
is prince louis made front page
headlines after being snapped pulling
faces at the queen's platinum jubilee
not happy about the noise that he heard
on the balconies the fly pass was going
on but they're taking a nice cuddle
from grandpa
good to see these pictures i think
that's a wimbledon by the looks of
things i think but uh nice to see the uh
prince and princess having a nice time
and why wouldn't they be
hello there and welcome back now the
latest polling in the tory leadership
contest puts liz trust well ahead of
rishi soon i can support from the party
members who of course will decide who
wins let's get the thoughts of two young
members of the conservative party i'm
pleased to say we're joined now by 20
year old 21 year old tory councillor
hanan sarwa who is undecided but said to
be leaning towards liz trust and we've
got ben souter who is 16 and a member of
the romford young conservatives and is
backing rishi sunay hanan and ben good
morning to you both thanks for being
with us and then first of all to you i
said you were leaning towards this trust
is that right are you thinking trust is
the better candidate
hi good morning yeah for me whoever
becomes the next prime minister they
have one goal and one aim and that is a
uniting the conservative party and
making sure we're in a position to fight
the next general election and able to
retain our
red wall seats that turn blue in 2019
under boris johnson and for me from what
i'm seeing in the polls from what i'm
speaking hearing um from members but i'm
speaking to them and what i'm actually
watching on social media on the debates
and on the hustlings liz trust is coming
across as a much stronger candidate and
i think currently as it stands she is
probably best suited to take over boris
johnson and be the continuity candidate
and deliver on all manifesto pledges
saying that the contest is still very
early i do like rishi sunak and there's
a lot to play for in the coming days and
weeks before we get our ballot papers
and i vote
and ben do you agree with that analysis
of
holding onto the red wall and that liz
truss uh would be the better placed
person to hold on to that red wall
um i think that should be the one aim of
the tory party and it's to hold on to
the red wall that we won in 2019 with
boris johnson i do not think liz trust
is the right person to lead us through
the next general election and that's
because rishi has a real plan which he's
had a plan for so long
he i've been supporting him even before
boris resigned i always said to my
fellow younger service members where
she's going to be the next prime
minister
that's because he's always had a plan
and he's always delivered for the people
but ben you'll know that some of the
conservative party members think of him
as a bit of a brutus character stabbing
boris johnston in the back how do you
answer that criticism
i don't agree there was 60 government
resignations on in that day in the two
days that before boris resigned
and there was less of no confidence and
we saw the no confidence vote
um where
boris only just got in
and i think that
rishi
didn't this isn't orchestrated people
were upset in the party
because of boris johnson's behavior i
myself was didn't like the way it was
orchestrated i think the members should
have had a say in what happened
but that's the rules of the party and
that's what we live with so
but i do think that this isn't rishi's
fault this isn't an orchestrated attack
helen what do you think about that is it
rishi's fault i mean there are lots of
uh um accusations flying around that he
was the one that stabbed
boris johnson in the back
i am no fan of boris johnson i think
towards the end of his 10 years trip he
did become a liability for the
conservative party but one of the main
reasons we removed him was that he
received a fine drawing party again and
rich kitsuna also was fined uh in
partygate so he isn't going to give us a
clean start or a fresh break from
everything that's happened in downing
street and westminster and my biggest
worry with rishi is if we do elect him
as our leader he will have my full
support but he is still tainted with the
party gate scandal and the labour party
can use that against us and rishi over
the course of the campaign has made
various u-turns on tax curse on china on
eu regulation and for me the biggest
problem is he was our chancellor yes he
delivered furlough yes he did the bounce
back scheme but he did increase taxes
and it's not you you can't be a
conservative and increase taxes it's
just in my opinion not viable so for me
liz project is offering a really clear
um sort of plan for when when should you
elect a prime minister she will take
bold steps to to allow our economic
growth to to develop she will go on go
to the eu and slash red tape to help
farmers and to help our our our economy
and on top of that she's actually
willing to take immediate support on the
cost of living and the start of the
campaign i i really liked penny morden
and i hope she would be on the on the
final too but that's not the case in the
last 24 hours or so we've seen ben
wallace penny morden tom tukenhart
figures across the conservative party
from a wide range of backgrounds
endorsing liz and for me that is like a
taster of her future cabinet which looks
extremely strong and with rishi i
haven't seen that yet and hannah in the
beginning of your answer there you
mentioned uh flip-flopping and u-turns i
mean liz trusted a massive one yesterday
didn't she she had this policy about
cutting civil servants pay which would
affect people living in poorer parts of
the country perhaps in the red wall and
then she had to row back on it
immediately when she found out how
unpopular what's that say about her
judgment
this is why i'm entirely undecided
rishi's had about eight big um u-turns
in the like in this contest so far liz
had a u-turn yesterday on regional
payboards um so this is the problem we
have we need to hear from these
candidates and now get on to the real
substance and policy as to what they're
promising it's all well and good saying
we want economic growth but we now need
to see plans as to how this will be
delivered it's why i'm still undecided
and leaning more towards liz trust
because it seems like she has a better
group of mps supporting her a strong
strong support from the membership and
whoever becomes prime minister needs to
unite the conservative party because
it's these conservative members these
conservative activists these councillors
are going to go out knock on the
doorsteps and persuade people to vote
for the conservative party so it's now
time to get some real substance from
both rishi and liz as to what they're
going to do to level up liz is always
broken about broadband infrastructure
she's spoken about slashing the red tape
fixing the protocol tackling on russia
so i need to hear more from rishi as to
what he would do
to beat liz and what what is his
different perspective that makes him
better suited to become prime minister
yeah i mean we're going to hear i'm sure
plenty of that in the sky news debate
tomorrow night at eight but bengal and
you heard that there hannah says that
he's still a little undecided he's
leaving supposedly but persuade him that
your man rishi is the one that he should
vote for
i'd just like to quickly go back to what
hannah said about the uh the pandemic
and how rishi was the chancellor at the
time there was an economic global crisis
and a pandemic that we'd never ever
expect
that is an unprecedented
situation for a chancellor to be in and
rishi handled it amazingly saving 11.6
million jobs through the furlough scheme
helping millions through his sciss
schemes to help the self-employed
and i think
rishi has a proven track record to make
sure
that he can deliver for this country
once he's elected uh in september he has
a plan and he always has done and he
ha he has the experience his experience
for the last two years dealing with the
pandemic and he knows the way to fight
back from that
okay we run out of time guys but i
thought that was great thank you both
very much ben suter from ron ferdinand
sawa from wilmslowtown council thanks
both
now moving on and intimidation and
sexualization is still a huge problem
for female and non-binary djs that's
according to a new report now we've
spoken to one dj who told us of her
experience of being assaulted while she
was at work and how it led her to stop
wearing skirts and dresses bethany
mannell reports on the study which also
looked at how well women are represented
in the industry
how are we feeling out there
playing to a record-breaking crowd at
the uefa women's euro 2022 opening match
but a new report has found that the
music industry is far from a level
playing field for female or non-binary
djs spearheaded by dj jaguar the study
into gender representation in uk dance
music found that just five percent of
music in the charts is from women and
non-binary artists alone 58 of tracks
feature male artists only leaving 37 of
dance tracks featuring artist
collaborations between genders
but steps are being taken to encourage
women and non-binary artists to step
behind the decks
being the only girl in the room you do
you do just feel like unwelcome and you
feel like you can't really reach your
true potential and i think having people
around you that you can relate to that
look like you makes you feel like oh
maybe i can try that out
and while djing can seem like the dream
job the study also highlighted the
intimidation and the sexualization
experienced by many female and
non-binary artists while in the
workplace
this is quite difficult to say but i've
been sexually assaulted at work
and
i did report it
nothing happened
i stopped wearing skirts
and i've stopped wearing dresses just
because i know that when i'm bending
down on the decks i'd have people taking
pictures of my skirt
and lessons learned from the deep dive
into dance music are applicable to the
wider music industry too just revealing
some of these new statistics that we've
come up with and all these amazing
quotes from
artists and people in the industry
that have been so wonderful and coming
forward with all of their their
perspectives
all of that hopefully just increases
that momentum
in an industry long dominated by men
change could take time but it'll be
music lovers who'll be the real winners
if the field is opened up for all
bethany minnell sky news
hello and welcome back now a new survey
suggests as many as one in three school
children are going to school without
having eaten one charity magic breakfast
aims to help fix that and break down the
barrier that hunger can create to
education by setting up breakfast clubs
i'm pleased to say that we're joined by
a head teacher who's seen the effect
that hunger can have on learning that's
helen ryan from dunscombe primary school
and the director of fundraising and
development at magic breakfast emily
wilkie good morning to you both emily
and helen first of all to you emily just
tell us what kind of programs are you
guys putting in place to try and make
sure that um kids get fed first thing in
the morning
yeah absolutely well unfortunately as
you said the situation at the moment uh
is a crisis we have as many as 2.6
million children at risk of starting
their school day having had nothing to
eat
and this has a huge impact on their
ability to learn we know that in magic
breakfast a hungry child is unable to
concentrate affects their behavior
so what we do is we offer a healthy
breakfast and expert support so that
those children can have the breakfast
without stigma at the start of the day
so that we can unlock their education
and learning
and helen uh to you tell us about some
of the kids that you're seeing who are
coming in who haven't been able to have
breakfast before starting school what
does that do to the way that they start
the school day
well i think first of all um
like emily says there's a big link to
attainment and how how they're going
into lessons um
i think it's more than that um a child
that hasn't had breakfast that's coming
in hungry they their behavior will start
to be affected um they'll be emotionally
dysregulated
um and
they won't they won't be ready to learn
they won't feel settled so um that's why
kind of breakfast clubs are so important
at duncan
and tell us about how those breakfast
clubs work then what kind of things are
the kids being given what kind of
breakfast are they getting is it
porridge is it cereal like what do they
get
they get great breakfast actually um
they can get porridge cereal scrambled
eggs pancakes
it's a really calm atmosphere it's open
from seven o'clock in the morning
there's board games to play
um craft reading and
we also run sports sessions twice a week
just to get everyone's heart moving a
bit
and they're really really popular so we
call it a soft start you can come from
seven in the morning until 8 30
and we find that children um are really
settled and then ready to start the day
okay uh helen ryan and emily will you
have to leave it run out of time but
thank you so much for being with us and
keep up that work thank you very much
thank you
all right let's take a look at some
images from the newspapers this morning
that we really like the looks of this is
from the telegraph
impressive that is a cartwheel galaxy
made up of bright and made of a bright
inner ring the image was released by
nasa yesterday it shows uh cluster of
galaxies thought to have been formed
after a high speed collision 400 million
years ago not bad at all and here's one
from the times that is acrobatic it
shows a ukrainian circus joining forces
with a group of czech performers to
bring a new show called boom to the
edinburgh fringe this year has a hell of
a leap there another lady in the back
and the daily mirror shell shocked in
the mirror shows an escaped giant
tortoise decided to crawl along some
train tracks on monday morning bringing
train services to a halt that brings a
new meaning to a slow-moving train i
guess